find the defendant guilty find the
defendant guilty
again in minnesota a white police
officer is convicted of killing a black
man kim potter lowered her head as she
was found guilty of first and
second-degree manslaughter for fatally
shooting 20-year-old dante wright as she
was taken into custody with no chance of
bail her husband shouted his support
as police sought to arrest ride on a
warrant after an april traffic stop
potter says he resisted arrest and she
fired what she thought was a taser
the weapon she drew was her gun potter
expressed remorse and tear-filled
testimony i
remember yelling taser taser taser
and nothing happened
and then
he told me i shot him
the shooting came as protesters some of
them violent filled the streets of
minneapolis during the trial of derek
chauvin a white police officer
ultimately convicted of killing another
black man george
protesters rushed to the scene of the
right shooting as the verdict came
inside the courthouse
[Applause]
wright's family celebrated outside the
moment that we heard guilty
on the
manslaughter one
emotions every single emotion that you
could imagine just running through your
body at that moment
i kind of let out a yelp
some residents too expressed relief
i'm really excited it's a good day it's
a good christmas gift
for the blue movement and for the family
of dante wright now that he got his
justice i feel a little more at ease but
definitely when that first happened i
was scared to even get in the car
minnesota's attorney general seemed to
feel vindicated we have a degree of
accountability
for dante's death
accountability is not justice
justice justice is restoration
justice would be restoring dante to life
and making the right family whole again
justice is beyond the reach
that we have in this life
for dante
but accountability is an important step
a critical
necessary step on the road to justice
for us all
that road he says is a long one potter
faces a maximum of 15 years sentence on
the first degree charge and 10 on the
second but guidelines call for
substantially less in any case potter is
likely to spend years in prison
as potter awaits sentencing on february
18th outside the courthouse where
looting and arson followed george
floyd's death in the summer of 2020 the
streets were mostly quiet
john hendren al jazeera minneapolis